die fans die an uns vorbei und wir haben
einfach liessen sich nicht und was man
auch sagen muss das war so ein pärchen
ich hätte jetzt mal so auf 25 bis 30
geschätzt da gibt es eine schöne
romantische abend bei den zuhause
mich hat gewundert dass kein wein
gekauft und keine blumen keine kondome
und herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja ich hoffe natürlich jedes gute
leute heute folgende planen ich habe das
selbst in den kommentaren gelesen also
dieses video entsteht komplett
ich hab's ja nicht selber ausgedacht
sondern nur bei euch das buch schreibt
mir weitere ideen wenn ihr den habt
einfach immer in die kommentare
ich lese mir fast alle durch mach das
bitte danke oder bei insgesamt 30 alex
wie könnt ihr auf machen sonst hab ich
ja vorgeworfen zeitraum immer diese
videos gemacht genug raum und zeit
trauen sagt man das nicht so vor
geraumer zeit vor geraumen zeitraum und
zwar vor geraumer zeit diese videos
gemacht ich kaufe das gleiche wie die
person form im apple store im saturn bei
mcdonald's so was halt von da in letzter
zeit immer mehr mit essen mache haben
wir uns heute gedacht aufgrund einer
idee joel extrem ein supermarkt einkauft
genau das gleiche wie der kunde der vor
die rein geht halt so schlimm mit
einkaufswagen und so am besten das heißt
wir sind heute auf einer undercover
mission
wir haben hier noch diese kleine kam
dabei und verfolgen die nächstbeste
kundin oder den nächstbesten kunden film
den halt so leicht wird natürlich alles
zensiert keine frage und kaufen genau
das gleiche das ist die erste challenge
da geht es allerdings noch weiter also
der plan geht noch weiter wie das
aussieht erkläre ich euch gleich im auto
weil wir müssen erst mal zu einem großen
supermarkt fahren wo wir also wo halt
wirklich so dieses ich will halt dass da
jemand mit einkaufswagen geht und so
weiß wie ich mein deswegen und hier in
der umgebung gehen die meisten halt
einfach die hier wohnen gehen da hin
deswegen fahren wir zu einem großen
supermarkt
so alfred so muss ich hier die von ihr
nehmen die mit fürst die ich will den
job können die wahrscheinlich so die
kommentare hashtag julis waschmaschine
steht alex mehr stopp bei muslimen vor
vielleicht irgendwie seinem
youtube-channel zu gründen oder so
waschmaschinen text gips habe ich sehr
wohl persil was ihm am besten hey schon
immer mit perwoll gewaschen fahrbereit
und alles soweit eingeladen mit kobold
mit perwoll ich sag mal so also ich
bevorzuge eigentlich eher persil weil
das habe ich das zu einer werbung
gesehen und die haben ja einfach persil
darauf gefasst auf den knopf drücken
ich habe ja marie catherine ashton
ehrlich zu sein kann ich das auch so
leute wir sind jetzt angekommen am lidl
firma das pärchen noch drauf ich habe es
gar nicht drauf da ist raten pärchen
reingegangen das waren also ich finde
wir können ja nehmen oder deswegen wir
gehen jetzt einfach rein suchen ihren
kaufmann genau das gleiche
ok das heißt wir fühlen dass hier mit
dieser kleinen camp dann würde ich sagen
verlieren wir jetzt gar nicht viel zeit
die große lassen wir hier und ich hoffe
wir machen gute aufnahmen ich
kommentiere das sonst nach wenn wir
nicht sagen
bis gleich okay leute was gedacht ich
kommentiere das ganze jetzt weil
manchmal ist halt einfach kein ton aber
es ist trotzdem was passiert und damit
ihr das versteht let's go
ach so ja gut hier sind wir erst mal zum
einkaufen gegangen herholz einkaufswagen
hast ja auch immer so zurück gebracht
hast dir noch immer so zurück
okay wir sind jetzt hier rein gegangen
es war erstmal chaos am anfang
[Musik]
mein kameramann also der liebe juli hat
sich darüber aufgeregt dass es ihm
unangenehm ist die kamera zu halten und
ich fand es witzig deswegen lasse ich
mich jetzt hier gleich kaputt
genau ok und jetzt haben wir die beiden
gesucht weil die waren halt schon länger
da drin es war ein mega komisch die halt
so zu finden und dann halt so immer in
diesen einkaufswagen rhein zu stocken
weil das ist ja wirklich stocken
und ich bin ja kein stalker es war ja
nur für dieses video und ich muss hier
mal kurz pausieren ich habe einfach die
ganze zeit nicht das passende produkt
gefunden was halt in deren wagen lag ich
hab immer so reingeguckt und dann dachte
ich okay das muss jetzt suchen aber ich
habe es einfach nicht gefunden und das
war bei den ersten drei sachen so danach
ging es besser deswegen bin ich wirklich
drei mal dahin gelangt okay er hat juli
wieder die verfolgung aufgenommen also
die kamera stand halt einfach im wagen
drin damit es nicht auffällt
das marine
und hier bin ich eine zeitlang gelagert
reingeguckt da lag eine pizza drin die
haben immer wieder reingelegt warum auch
immer keinen plan
und hier kann man ja da kann man sehen
wir legen jetzt halt wieder dieser
smoothie und so2 salami teile drin
die habe ich dann auch gefunden und die
haben wir dann auch bei uns rein getan
ich habe
ich werde mich jetzt zwischen die kamera
so dass wir dich nicht sieht
okay das war sehr wichtig weil viele
leute also die auch dort eingekauft
haben wir haben auf unsere kamera
geguckt dann haben wir einfach eine
colaflasche daneben gelegt damit das
nicht so krass ausfällt
ja das war halt auch weniger auffällig
oder genau der ist auf der anderen seite
lang gingen deswegen muss ich mich so
ducken damit ich noch mal sehen kann was
ja gerade alles genommen hat juni war es
einfach den ganzen der 20 mal gemacht
junge das mission angenehm
ich bin gleich wieder da ich habe gerade
überlegt ich finde so auf die sachen auf
die schnelle nicht aus einem schweren
wagen fotografieren also perfekt machen
was sie noch vor haben
nein
ich wollte ihn fotografieren den wagen
aber man sieht nichts weiter machen
black hawk etwas gutes ich habe jetzt
deren wagen fotografiert so weil der
standort an der ecke ist da noch
irgendwas was sie nicht haben
okay leute sind uns an der kasse der ja
das ist so heftig auf geheimer mission
schwarz das ist nicht auflaufen
ich wundere mich quasi über manche ja
und hier bin ich dann zur kasse gefahren
die waren fertig und habe mich halt an
die andere kasse gestellt da wird es
nicht zu offensichtlich ist und dort
halt einfach genau das gleiche
okay leute wir sind jetzt wieder zurück
im auto das gute war die waren nach dem
parkplatz wir haben auch so ein foto in
bekommen alter das foto ist so heftig
geworden habe es wahrscheinlich am haben
schon gesehen also das was so künstlich
zum auto gelaufen ich halte eine tolle
serien auf
auf jeden fall wenn ich jetzt zu
gedenken
also ich habe mir die situation so voll
entspannt vorgestellt dass man einfach
so undercover film aber das war so
schwierig die ganze zeit halt zusehen
okay ich habe am ende noch versucht
deren biographien das hat aber irgendwie
nur so halb gefasst und das doch mal zu
gucken ob wir wirklich alles haben
aber wenn ihr halt irgendwas aus dem
regal nehmen bis du das dann selber erst
mal findest und auch in deinen wagen
tust dann sind sie schon wieder weg dann
musste die suche das gute war klar man
steht auch manchmal so und guckt was wir
haben möchte aber was die leute kauft
haben ich habe nur mist jetzt reiß und
bisschen gemüse habe ich noch nicht
gesehen also wir das lincoln im
kofferraum und versam ist und eher gut
die hat schon gegessen oder nicht oder
hast du auf gemacht zumindest wir gucken
uns das gleich mal an und dann schauen
wir mal was man daraus machen kann oder
also ich bin mal gespannt das ganze hat
übrigens knapp 14 euro kostet 13 euro
für 92 es war also eigentlich noch ein
relativ entspannter einkaufen und was
man auch sagen muss das war so ein
pärchen ich hätte jetzt mal so auf 25
bis 30 geschätzt oder so die halt
wahrscheinlich dass jetzt kochen werden
also jeweils 18 uhr 21 da gibt es einen
schönen romantischen abend bestimmt bei
den zuhause
mich hat es gewundert dass kein wein
gekauft wurden keine gummi und man keine
kondome
aber wir haben die noch haben die noch
zu hause roccoli einstimmig drei die
kenne ich die verhüten nicht mehr weiß
vielleicht vielleicht sollte heute abend
passieren dass heute abend sich
fortpflanzen dreht vielleicht wird heute
ein baby gemeint daumen hoch wenn alex
meier kehren so wie man babys macht so
ist also leute ich habe dass ich hier
meine tüte gepackt jetzt zeige ich
irgendwann mal schnell was wir alles
gekauft haben ich das jetzt einfach mal
kurz und zwar als ich habe keinen plan
wie das alles hin zu sagen und die
braucht vielleicht alarmiert die haben
wir salami dann haben wir werden dann
haben wir in afrika aber ich es auch auf
die farbe achtet also die wir auch bei
denen droht dann haben wir brokkoli
also ich muss sagen früher mit brokkoli
gehasst aber mittlerweile zeit das
richtige portfolio ist echt lecker dann
haben wir hier rama zum koffern absolut
immer daran sieht man auch wieder die
wollen heute abend wirklich was kommt
dann vielleicht war es ja auch deren
erstes date man kann ja nicht man könnte
ja nicht wissen
das finde ich interessant wo war dein
erstes date
nein so neben erste wo bei den öffis
bild kino fünf kämpfen oder kann man
damals so sich langsam so so rand werden
links doppelsitz dann haben wir hier
reis also preis ist wahrscheinlich so
die grundzutaten das ganze
die machen davon welchen können hilft
auch hier haben wir hähnchen und dann
habt ihr hier ist und genießt es
wahrscheinlich dass da mal die frauen
richtiger salami und hier gibt es musik
danach kann ich ja irgendwie nicht
aussprechen aber ich muss jetzt erst mal
probieren das nur sieben von zehn
bewertungen echt lecker bis hin zu süß
deswegen gibt es mir an dieser stelle
von senden
du kannst ja immer ein bisschen dran
kommen und hier einmal den film also
sieht das ganze aus ich würde sagen das
video ist ja schon lange
deswegen machen wir da jetzt
schlauerweise weil es hier auf meinem
kanal jeden tag erst um 19 oder 20 uhr
neues video gibt im zweiten part post wo
wir das kochen und ihr schreibt mir
bitte mal das rezept von diesen ganzen
zutaten in die kommentare
was das werden soll wer mega wichtig das
war's vom video lassen doch nach oben da
abonniert meinem account aktiviert die
glocke folge weist deutschland gerichtet
sein